we're going to turn to Ukraine now where
there was an air alert spanning the
entire country this morning as Russia
stepped up attacks from above in the
capital city these strikes are the worst
since the start of the war according to
the mayor there and Russia is escalating
ahead of what has been a widely
anticipated counter-offensive from
Ukraine Charlie dagada has more now from
inside the country
Tracer fire streaks across the skyline
then
a direct hit intercepting an incoming
missile Russia has gone on the attack
ahead of Ukraine's counter-offensive
few believe the country would last a
month against Russia now this Army of
underdogs is gearing up for a battle
that could prove pivotal in the course
of the war
training at a quarry 15 miles from the
front line even though many of these
recruits have zero experience they're
trained on every weapon in the Arsenal
for whatever the battle may bring
their instructor Spartacus has been
fighting the Russians since 2014. so
what kind of weapons are you training
these Soldiers with uh we got a Soviet
weapon and American Weapon It's American
grenades M65 baseball frag
it's a 40 millimeter grenades
call sign zuke is a high school history
teacher you mentioned your goals and
your purpose what is that goal to come
back home with Victory soon he said and
everyone will return to the normal life
that we've all lost as both sides
prepare for the battle ahead Ukrainian
troops are determined to win this war by
the Year's End whatever Victory looks
like for CBS mornings Charlie dagada
eastern Ukraine